[ __ ] the focus do I go higher lower all
right there we go thanks sorry all right
now it's in focus I know what I'm
talking about
hey guys Brian right here hope you
enjoyed my hilarious opening bit there
so yeah I just literally finished
watching the first episode of daredevil
have to talk about this show I [ __ ]
loved it I'm doing binge watching all
the Marvel movies specifically started
from Ironman so that way I could you
know really prepare for Avengers age of
Ultron so I'm getting really used to
like what the Marvel stuff feels like
watching this did not feel like anything
I've seen from Marvel before it was
really dark it was really gritty it's
violent like in the first 10 minutes
you see daredevil [ __ ] annihilate
abag guy just like punching the [ __ ] out
of him and the fighting style too you
could tell it's just it's a real human
being who's doing all this work and the
Marvel films I'm not gonna compare it to
much but in the Marvel films you feel
like oh they're usually okay if they're
up against one person but you put
daredevil up against one guy and you're
very much aware that he's a blind dude
it's intense it makes it much more
tension fill the entire time I liked it
from the intro you see daredevil when
he's a little guy Matt Murdock I think
is his name then he becomes blind that
was actually really effective because
you start thinking about like oh man
that must really suck to be in that
father's position to have a blind kid
but then again you could [ __ ] with the
kid a little bit you could just like
make faces at em oh I'm kidding
it's all jokes around here and then he's
in the confessional I love that line
it's so action hero like when he says
that cool line that I'm totally gonna
quote right now that I can so remember
I'm not asking for forgiveness for what
I've done I'm asking for forgiveness for
what I'm about to do right from that
moment I was like oh [ __ ]
shits about to go down and when he [ __ ]
up those people inside of the cargo
spots heroes always save the day in
cargo areas I noticed that Batman Begins
and sure enough said that sentences
that's the only other one I could think
of that the fight sequences I thought
were awesome I've seen a lot of
television shows where the characters
are like they know martial arts they
know how to fight whatever but they're
never full-on like cinematic fight
sequences this kind of reminded me of
like it was like stylish but it was also
like MMA style ah people are saying this
kind of like the raid that level of
brutality mixed with sort of a level of
beauty I really do dig that kind of
violence in the show I thought that mom
was very powerful when he was beating up
that one dude at the end where he's just
like keeps punching him in the face
because none of the other Marvel heroes
they're not gonna do that but daredevil
you see just how violent this show is
gonna be and just how much darker this
person's soul is compared to like the
other heroes were used to I like the guy
places partner foggy
he's foggy I think of a homophobic word
when I hear that but I can't say it
because it's a fucked-up word but you're
all thinking it so you're all [ __ ] up
for thinking it foggy foggy I thought
was fun you know you like II do need
that comic relief type of character I
like how him and Matt are partners yet
matt is aware that he kind of does dirty
things on the side you know like he
snorts cocaine and goes to strip clubs
and stuff no I'm just kidding it's more
jokes here the real rejects what he does
is like Hebrides cops and to get
information stuff I like the set up of
them being lawyers starting up their
firm on that very day and how they
approach their first client the girl who
plays Paige
she was Jessica on True Blood you see
her side boob in the show in the first
episode but in True Blood you see full
boob so watch True Blood if you the side
boob wasn't good enough for you
is that okay that I said that yeah okay
go all right well thanks baby she was
great that introduction when you know
she has her bleeding hands and you know
my idiotic mind was like who's a little
peer reviewed but then you know you see
that there's a dead body there and
you're like oh it's not a period it's a
dead body and it looks like she's sad
but she's freaking out and you do
believe that she didn't kill this guy
she's a great actress she really does
sell like damaged person very well
hopefully she's okay in real life but I
don't care it makes her great
entertainment on screen but I like the
connection that form is I thought the
lawyer stuff was great
they have like a lawyer show inside of
this you know superhero vigilantes show
is cool because the lawyer stuff all the
cases that they're dealing with was all
really interesting actually like I
wasn't boarding stuff to listen to his
like it wasn't like can we just get her
when he's being daredevil again you're
actually paying attention and you're
getting good character development out
of these sequences with all this lawyer
case stuff that's going on and it links
to daredevil being daredevil where well
it's not just like Daredevils like okay
I'm looking for another case and then
it's like he comes in when he's really
necessary to come in but if he can do it
just as Matt Murdock he'll do it just as
Matt
[ __ ] mad and beautiful dude he's cool
he's really cool like the way he talks
he's putting on like a character when
he's talking but he's also like sincere
at the same time he's very charming
I would consider a threesome with him
baby just so you know he would have to
wear the glasses though
he needs mean that walking stick with
him too there was a really scary moment
I mean I knew she wasn't gonna die
exactly she was a series regular on the
show but when she's being hung by the
prison's guard
I like how they set up the prison guard
because you see that he's a guy who has
his daughter's life is on the line
because of a mistake that he made he
doesn't know exactly who he has to kill
so you're not like looking at this guy
who you normally would just be like in a
show like oh that's just another bad guy
working for the bad dudes he's not in
the show a lot but they made his
character important enough to establish
like no this is a very character-driven
show
I like that daredevil can tell that you
know when someone's lying by their
heartbeat I did it to my girlfriend if
she gets turned on while we're watching
a movie it's in her stomach this is
serious thing I'll be laying on counters
Center in my head over a stack on her
stomach and if there's someone hot on
screams her stomach starts breathing
awkward and if I say is he hot jugo no I
know she's lying cuz her heartbeats
going
and so yeah daredevil and I have that in
common when it comes down to the finale
I love that last fight because you don't
know this assassin really you just heard
a couple of sentences about the guy you
see him fight with daredevil and that's
what I'm talking about that moment you
really get that daredevil is a human
being you don't feel like he's a
superhero actually you feel like this is
a real fighter I like seeing how this is
the
origins of daredevil not just in the
terms of daredevil but in terms of also
being a lawyer by the way if you're
gonna be a vigilante you don't do that
at the same time for starting up a law
firm that's just too much stress on your
plate I like that I haven't showed us
Wade Wilson yet kingpin I like how they
haven't showed us the villain yet
they're really setting him up well it's
so brilliant that it's on Netflix
because you can toy binge watch this
[ __ ] and I'm excited to continue
watching this show I'm excited for the
upcoming appearances I like their subtle
hints at the Marvel world like when the
bad businessmen are talking they're
saying how like every time one of these
superheroes [ __ ] up that their
business goes up like I like those
little hints but they're not trying to
like tie it in and be like hey look
marvel but they're doing it very slowly
anyway guys thank you so much for
telling me the release date of daredevil
so excited to be watching it if you're
new to the channel you can subscribe to
the real rejects and you can follow me
on Facebook Instagram and Twitter
because I'm a youtuber and youtubers
need followers on more than just YouTube
apparently because then you look like
you're not cool and you're not
successful if I don't have a lot of
Twitter followers